there's a loneliness in me that's I'm
always longing to connect with people
and with like regular people and like
just to to learn their stories and so on
and so if you open yourself up that way
the things they tell you can really hurt
in every way like uh just have me going
to Ukraine just seeing so much loss and
death
some of it is like
uh is I mean unforgettably haunting not
in some kind of political way activist
way or uh who's right who's wrong way
but just like
man like so much pain you see it just
stays with you when you see a human
being bad to another human you can't get
rid of that in your head
you can't imagine that you that that we
can treat each other like that that's
the hard part I think I mean it is it
that for me it is
when I saw parents like when I did the
child exploitation stuff when they
rented their children out they literally
rented infant children out to others for
sexual gratification
like I don't know how a human being
could do that to another human being
and that that sounds like the kind of
thing you're going through I mean I went
through a huge Funk when I did those
cases afterwards I should have talked to
somebody but in the FBI you have to keep
that machismo up or they're gonna take
your gun away from you well I think
that's examples of evil
um
that that's like the worst of human
nature but it's like just because I have
war is just as bad I mean somehow War
it's somehow understandable given all
the very intense propaganda that's
happening
so it's you can understand
um
that there is love in the heart of the
soldiers on each side given the
information they're given there's a lot
of people on the Russian side believe
they're saving these Ukrainian cities
from Nazi occupation
uh now there is stories
uh there is a lot of evidence of people
for fun murdering civilians now that
that is closer to the things you've
experienced of like evil yeah uh of evil
embodied and I haven't interacted with
with that directly with people who for
fun murdered civilians but you know it's
there in the world I mean you're not
naive to it yes but if you experience
that directly if somebody shot somebody
for fun in front of me that would
probably break me yeah
like seeing it yourself knowing that it
exists is different than seeing it
yourself
now I've interacted with victims of that
and they tell me stories and you see
their homes destroyed destroyed for no
good military reason it's civilians with
civilian homes being destroyed that
really lingers with you but it's um yeah
the people that are capable of that but
that goes with the propaganda I mean if
you want to build a story you have to
you know you have to have on the other
side you know the homes are going to be
destroyed the non-military targets are
going to be destroyed to put it in
perspective I'm not sure a lot of people
understand the Deep human side or even
the military strategy side of this war
there's a lot of experts outside of the
situation that are commenting on it with
certainty and that kind of hurts me
because I feel like there's a lot of
uncertainty there's so much propaganda
it's very difficult to know what is true
um
yeah so so my whole Hope was
to travel to Ukraine to travel to Russia
to talk to soldiers to talk to leaders
to talk to real people that have lost
homes that have lost family members that
uh who this war has divided who this war
changed completely how they see the
world uh whether they have love or hate
in their heart to understand their
stories
um I've learned a lot on The Human Side
to things by having talked to a lot of
people there but it has been on the
Ukrainian side for me currently
traveling to the Russian side is more
difficult